hello good evening and welcome first of
all I just like to thank you all for
joining us tonight
and for this important debate on Darfur
and especially we want to thank mr. John
Prendergast professor rosenbloom and
professor Mamdani for being here I just
want to recognize some of the groups
that helped put this event together and
make this possible the the Institute of
for African Studies
dzifa's Pan African Network the
humanitarian affairs working group the
Graduate Committee on an African educate
African Studies the Center for African
education the conflict resolution
working group the UN Studies working
group the Arab Students Association the
center for international conflict
resolution and Brooklyn for peace
tonight our moderator is Professor Peter
Rosenblum he's a professor in human
rights at the fact and the faculty
co-director of the Human Rights
Institute at Columbia Law School
professor Rosenblum has worked with many
major international human rights groups
including Human Rights Watch and global
rights he is a member of the Human
Rights Watch Africa Division Advisory
Committee a consultant to the Carter
Center and serves on the board of
several nongovernmental organizations
much of his recent work has focused on
the confluence of natural resources and
human rights issues around the world
with special emphasis on Africa he'll
now take us through the debate format
and introduce our two debaters thank you
very much and thank you to the
organizers they and I think it's really
just a marvelous opportunity for us all
I think for any of us who have been
thinking about Darfur we have moments of
internal debate moments of struggle with
the issues and often when we reach out
to read what's in the public we start to
wonder whether such different views of
reality can coexist here's our
opportunity to to to see in in in action
to spokesman and articulate errs of
views that for in those terms often do
seem as if they must exist in in
separate worlds and
separate realities are we talking about
genocide elack's in a counterinsurgency
on the cheap or a planned and organized
genocide from the very top with ethnic
and racial dimensions are we talking
about 400,000 dead or a hundred thousand
are we talking about a problem
understandable in the abstract or one
that can only be understood with a deep
understanding of context in terms of
colonialism imperialism and the war on
terror all of these I think are our
issues that hopefully we'll be hearing
about tonight we're going to leave it to
our speakers to define those issues and
to lay out the terms of the debate and
then to be able to respond to each other
the terms the the arrangement that we
have will be for each speaker first to
present their for their their view of
the problem of Darfur and Sudan John
Prendergast will speak first and then
mom would Mamdani after that each will
talk for 15 minutes again about the way
forward and then in the final ten
minutes each will will will offer some
rebuttal statements or final statements
before we go on to 30 to 40 minutes of
question-and-answer before I turn to the
speakers I just wonder if we might for
for the speakers and for ourselves get a
sense of who we have in the audience
today how many of you are undergraduates
at Columbia or elsewhere in the
community and how many of you are in a
ph.d program at Columbia or elsewhere in
the community how many of you are in one
of the professional schools the School
of Public Health or Teachers College the
law school SEPA now what have I left out
I don't know a nursing school I'm not so
sorry
social work all right yes okay and then
other others other people in the
community oh my god invaders from
another galaxy
yes excellent okay all right well thanks
very much I am expecting unfortunately
or fortunately I'm expecting a very
civil discussion I turns out that our
two speakers seem to get along well I
thought I was gonna have to sit between
them and and I was already considering
you know my lost friendships that along
the way but no I think we're off to a
wonderful evening so thanks very much
I'm not gonna go on describing the two
of them because I think you all know why
they're here so I'll just leave it since
I got to be introduced but I wasn't in
the program then a lot I'll hold that
over on the others great feeder thanks a
lot I may be an explanation for why work
along so well I I can be a fairly
contentious cantankerous even
carcinogenic person at times mind you
and since I actually like professor mom
Donny a great deal as a human being I
decided to eat decided to eat all my
chocolate Easter bunnies on the way up
here on the train ride so I'd be really
nice and sweet tonight so I hope it
works and I saved an extra bunny for you
professor medical if you're nice to me
too
a second thing before I start is that as
one begins to glide into midlife when
one reaches the age that most of us are
beset you know by some of the usual
questions of identity and purpose so in
doing my research on professor mom
Donny's positions regarding the topic
tonight I was relieved to have a number
of my identity issues answered by his
writings it turns out that as a being a
Sudan activist as I am I have learned
from from his writings that I'm actually
a neocon controlled by Jewish lobbies
who want to Save Darfur through military
occupation as a result of the war on
terror which sharpens my focus on
demonizing Arabs and ultimately fronts
from my desire to recolonize Africa it's
all clear now I know what my purpose is
in life so seriously though in this
first section in this first part of the
debate and discussion
we are talking about the problem in
Sudan so we're going to follow these
rules accordingly and rather than get
too abstract right off the bat I just
like to start with today's problems as
in April 14 2009 and and try to put
myself in the shoes of a refugee or a
displaced person if I was one of the
nearly two million displaced people in
Darfur today living in one of the camps
I have a few problems of a fairly
immediate nature it turns out that since
President Bashir kicked out the main
NGOs servicing Darfur with humanitarian
assistance in my camp we no longer have
chlorinated water and I'm scared to
death for my kids that someone will
contact caller as someone and somewhere
in the camp and then we'll really be up
the creek because if one person
contracts it many many more will as it
spreads like wildfire I'm also concerned
that the NGO that used to and this is
something most of us don't know that
used to vacuum all of the human waste
out of the latrines on a daily basis no
longer does that since the day that
President Bashir issued his edict that
these NGOs must leave human right waste
is spreading everywhere in my camp and
the temperatures are going up in Darfur
every week as we glide slowly into the
rainy season in less than two months and
this means that diseases will spread
crazily because of these conditions
now I haven't even begun as a resident
of this camp to think about the coming
interruptions in food and medicine due
to the expulsion but they are coming we
have been told by the RET agencies that
the pipeline is slowly closing down
because we don't have the service
delivery capacity and is embarrassing
frankly to even talk about one of my
most difficult problems and that is that
my 15 year old daughter was raped
looking for firewood
last week the NGO that was expelled in
our camp
have been documenting a rise in sexual
assaults by paramilitary groups roving
around the camps and the local
administrator have been telling the head
of that NGO that their days in Sudan
were numbered I guess he was right
so I myself only came back to the to my
family right there in the camp a few
months ago I had been with one of the
rebel groups but was fed up with the
infighting in this organization and the
abuses that the rebel group works
committing one day I just decided to
quit and come back and come back to the
camp now I hear rumors of a new
challenge
I hear about government attacks on IDP
camps and that part of the reason for
the NGO expulsion z' is to dismantle the
vast camp structure which has been sort
of the incubator for the continuing
rebellion in Darfur this would be
devastating I can tell you unless there
is peace we have nowhere to go as bad as
these camps are they are better than the
threats we face from predatory militias
that await us in our villages we come
from if we have to leave these camps if
these camps are broken up it is shameful
that we are reduced to hoping for some
kind of help from faraway lands and far
away people who have mercy on us but
that is where we are today that is the
problem
in Sudan today ladies and gentlemen that
is my attempt to summarize the immediate
challenges faced by Darfurians based on
the eight trips that I have taken
personally into Darfur since the most
recent conflict began in 2003 so how did
we get to this point
where some of the most self-reliant
people that I have never met in my life
the people of Darfur unfortunately are
just waiting for some solution to come
from someplace far away well I think for
the half century and now this is my
quick explanation for the half century
that that Sudan has been an independent
country it has been deeply deeply
troubled as we all know the former
colonizers of Sudan Egypt and Great
Britain
turned over a country at independence
that was profoundly unequal and for
these last five decades a very small
group at the center of Africa's largest
country has controlled everything and
used overwhelming force to destroy any
opposition we all probably know that the
largest manifestation of that inequality
and concentration of power has played
itself out in the southern part of the
country where the oil is most of the oil
at least where the southerners since
independence have fought two wars for
first independence and second for a new
Sudan as they call it though they will
get there referendum and things go as
planned which they never do in 2011 so
Darfur the western part of the country
is just the latest symptom of a disease
state called Sudan now to fight the
rebellion in Darfur the government of
Sudan committed what I believe though I
wouldn't fall on my sword for it what I
believe is genocide and genocide is a
unique crime in which the perpetrator as
the definition says intends to bring
about the conditions which will lead to
the destruction in whole or in part of a
particular group of people based on
their identities in this case the
government of Sudan has targeted three
non Arab ethnic groups for destruction
in that in the manner that the that the
genocide determination a Genocide
Convention outlines the four people the
Segawa people and the Massa leave people
now these aren't random ethnic groups
that the government is one day decided
to come after with helicopter gunships
and and paramilitary forces these are
the bulk the backbone just like the
Dinka were of the SPLA in the south
these were the backbone are the backbone
of the Darfurian rebel groups splintered
as they are and so they had decided made
a very clear decision that they were
going to target these groups the oldest
paramount the oldest counterinsurgency
strategy in the book drain the water to
catch the fish you try to cut the
umbilical cord between the liberation
movement or rebel group or militia or
whatever you want to call it insurgency
and the people who would provide its
sanctuary and support to allow that fish
to travel in the water of the Sahara
Desert so to accomplish the task of
destroying those ethnic groups in some
way shape or form the government of
Sudan decided to organize an armed the
militias that we have come to become two
that have come to be known here in the
West collectively as the John Dewey
they're a very decentralized and
dispersed set of militias and or and and
groups at the local level and they are I
think they are in some strange way
Darfur is version of the Ku Klux Klan
like the KKK they represent only a very
small percentage of the sentiment of the
people of Darfur the larger population
of Sudan and it's the most extreme
sentiment just as the KKK wasn't is here
in the United States but they have the
guns courtesy of the government of Sudan
in its counterinsurgency strategy of
contracting paramilitaries to to
undertake the ethnic cleansing that we
saw pre carried out in 2003 and for 2004
and they went about their work I think
with fairly deadly efficiency we have at
least satellite evidence and all of the
efforts that have been made to collect
testimonies on the ground and document
what what happened and where what what
went on and about a thousand five
hundred villages were burned to the
ground during that then the height of
the counterinsurgency that the main push
in oh three oh four and early 2005 this
isn't divide and conquer this is divide
and destroyed and it's not a secret it's
not a very hard to figure out why the
government would want to do this I mean
first and foremost
a lot to Lose they've been in power now
for 20 years committed a lot of
atrocities the first thing and they're
very unpopular regime and certainly will
would like to send a message to any
would-be rebel that this is the fate
that awaits you and they have a lot to
lose in the form of economic benefits as
we all know since the late 1990s Sudan
has catapulted from a exporter of gum
arabic to a mid-level producer of oil
and that oil is not going for
development building roads and
agricultural projects for the people of
all throughout Sudan that is going into
the coffers of many of the leading
figures in the National Congress party
the ruling party in Sudan and it goes
for buying weapons so it's maintained
power by any means necessary if you will
so ultimately the problems in Sudan
since that's the first panel the which
are you know the roots of conflict
maldevelopment marginalization over
concentration of power in the center and
a willingness to use any means necessary
to maintain that power it's a small
group of people these problems have been
left completely unaddressed by external
efforts and by the efforts of the with
the exception of the north-south peace
deal the efforts of Sudanese internally
and as long as they remain as long as
these problems these fundamental root
causes remain unaddressed then we're
going to continue to have forums like
this I think focus and on predictably on
the problems in Sudan so hopefully in
the second section when we go into the
we can get when we go into what must be
done the way forward I think is the
title then we will be able to talk about
the solutions because there are
solutions Africa is full of solutions
and I hope we can get a chance to talk
about some of them in that second
session thanks Peter thank you
I want to thank the students who
organized this I don't think I did any
research on John so I have nothing to
say about John what I have to say is
about the conflict in Darfur when I
first heard of the Darfur conflict I was
struck by one thing I work on one of the
things I work on his internal conflict
in Africa and I'm used to African
conflicts happening as if in the dead of
the night
Luanda Angola Congo but Darfur was
different
the our food seemed globalized a more
than life-size there seemed to be an
enormous media hype about Darfur
there was no problem of getting people
to know that there was a conflict and a
tragedy unfolding in Darfur and as I
followed this what I thought was an
unusual phenomenon and I asked myself
why I realized that the answer was very
simple the answer was that Darfur was
the subject of a domestic movement in
the US unlike Rwanda unlike Congo unlike
Angola and that movement had driven the
message it had even driven politics in
Congress it had been spectacularly
successful and I decided to follow this
message
his Rumsfeld would say connect the dots
so the first dot the first mega
publicity was about how many have died I
came across this in 2006 when the
Government Accountability Office which
is an audit agency of the US government
it got together with the u.s. Academy of
Sciences appointed 12 experts asked them
to look at six different estimates of
mortality in Darfur at the height of the
violence 2003-2004 asked them to look at
the methodology and to say which ones
were reliable which ones were not the
high end estimates were 400,000 coming
from Save Darfur connected researchers
and the low end was 70,000 coming from
the World Health Organization all 12
experts without exception said that the
Save Darfur estimates were the least too
reliable they were based on
unrepresentative samples and
generalizations over a vast population
the most reliable actually was cred
which had roughly an estimate which was
a w-h-o research affiliate in Europe
roughly an estimate of something like
112 thousand the difference between 112
thousand and four hundred thousand is
enormous that was 2006 but 2007 I kept
him seeing ads in Subway's in New York
City and on buses four hundred thousand
already dead from Save Darfur right with
absolutely no concern or interest in
what may be the truth on the ground I
became more interested in the dots the
second dot was about the causes of death
because the Save Darfur messages seem to
imply that these 400,000 had died of
violence they were killed and I realized
the
there was a difference between the
numbers killed and the numbers who had
died and the difference was that the
deaths were from multiple causes the
waho research in the credit research
pointed out that there were two causes
one cause was drought and
desertification the United Nations
environmental program pointed out last
year in its research that the southern
rim of the Sahara's had expanded a
hundred kilometers over 40 years from
the 40s to the 1980s and this expansion
had forced the nomads of the north down
south well the w-h-o estimates pointed
out that something like 70 to 80 percent
had died from the effects of drought in
desertification mostly young children
and infants who had died from diarrhea
and dysentery 20 to 30 percent had died
from direct violence now there is a
ground for legitimate debate and the
ground for legitimate debate is how many
of those who died of dysentery diarrhea
would have survived if there was no
conflict if assistance had come in time
and I don't deny that that's an area of
legitimate debate but all I'm pointing
out is that there was not one cause of
death there were multiple causes of
death there was a third factor which I
thought was enormous Lee was not
exaggerated it simply wasn't mentioned
what wasn't mentioned was that this
conflict had a history that the conflict
had actually begun even before the
present government in Sudan came into
power in 1987 89 if you read the
literature on Darfur and you talk to
researchers or people there on the
ground they will tell you that before
1987 conflicts win in Darfur were
between neighbors they were localized
and they were easily settled through
reconciliation conferences but something
changed in 1987
the conflict became an all Darfur
conflict the level of brutality was
horrendous and the numbers that died
were terrible the best writing on this
is by a Darfur II anthropologist called
sherry furrier who is today actually one
of the leaders of the rebel of one of
the rebel movements sharif career in his
writing sherry farad was present at the
resolution of the conflict in 1989 and
he recorded the speeches of the
secretaries on both sides both for
primary school teachers one interesting
thing is this that already in 1989 one
side was talking of genocide indeed the
word used is Holocaust not genocide and
the other side is talking of ethnic
cleansing both sides see themselves as
victims in the conflict that was 87 89
now why did the 87 89 conflict happen
the 87 89 conflict happened for three
reasons the first reason was a
background reason which is the nature of
colonialism in Darfur the nature of
British colonialism when it got control
of Darfur it divided up the land
completely between different tribes so
therefore became a patchwork of tribal
homelands except that peasant tribes got
large homelands and the most nomadic
tribes the camel tribes of the north got
no homeland because they had no settled
villages because they moved around the
year second cause was the drought and
desertification as the Sahara expanded
it pushed the northern nomads down south
and they headed for the best land in
Central Darfur around the mountain
massif known as double-murder
1770 kilometers of land and began a
classical ecological conflict in Darfur
the third contributory cause was that
Darfur was neighbor to Chad and there
was a civil war in Chad from 1960 from
independence onwards and the two sides
in the Civil War were armed by two sides
in the cold
by the 1980's the Reagan administration
France and Israel armed one side Gaddafi
and the Soviet Union arm the other side
by night mid-1980s there are forwards
without water but it was awash with guns
with ak-47s and that explained the level
of killing in this civil war in Darfur
my point is that the Western powers were
involved in the full conflict before the
government of Sudan was involved and
furthermore the present government was
not even in power at the time so if we
want to hold anybody accountable we
should begin with where the conflict
begins now let's go on to the present
phase of the conflict which begins in
2003 who is fighting home safe Darfur
has been talking of the Janjaweed I
worked as a consultant for the African
Union for a year and my job as a
consultant was basically to attend
meetings of traditional leaders like
Chiefs of political parties opposition
and government or for NGOs and community
groups of women's representatives of
intellectuals and of representatives of
IDPs to to read their reports to sit-in
to listen to the discussion and to say
which point of view was not being
covered and which issue was not being
represented in the discussion was an
ideal job for a researcher the group
that I worked for did a research and
what came out of this research on the
country was that actually the conflict
was along two axes north-south and
east-west the north-south conflict was
the one between the northern nomads and
the southern peasants which is where the
Janjaweed of the north comes in and the
south south conflict was between
different nomadic groups the only thing
that made sense of both the conflicts
was that it was everywhere between those
with homelands and those without
homelands this was the big factor but
the east-west conflict has been obscured
in the safe Darfur
messages the only talk of the
north-south conflict as an Arab African
country if anybody is interested we can
then discuss outside of my time limit
the question of Arab and African the
final question the final question was
that in my work I became aware that
actually after 2005 January the level of
deaths in Darfur had declined
dramatically three weeks ago I was at a
meeting in Addis Ababa of a of a African
Union panel on Darfur and one of the
people addressing the panel was the
commander of the UN forces in Darfur
17400 UN forces part of their job is to
follow up report of every death of a
civilian and file a report how many died
of what causes according to the
commander of the UN forces the total
number of civilian dead in Darfur
throughout the year 2008 were 1,500 that
is less than 135 a month less than what
would be considered an emergency by the
United Nations anywhere else in the
world but you would not know this if you
listened to Save Darfur I don't know
about John I hope that John is not
surprised by these figures but you
wouldn't know it if you listened to Save
Darfur propaganda you would think that
the situation is worsening
you would not know that there has been a
dramatic decline my final point is this
why did how much time we are there you
have four minutes for me is great why
did the violence go down the violence
went down unlike what you've heard the
violence went down because of the
African Union intervention the African
Union has been the only group in Darfur
which has begun with the assumption and
stuck to the assumption that the
solution to this problem can only be
political it cannot be a military
solution that the solution
not be an external intervention from the
outside a military-type intervention but
the only external intervention which
would make sense is one that would bring
different sides in the conflict together
the African Union is the only one that
managed to bring them together in Jimena
and when it brought them together there
was an agreement with the big powers in
the West the agreement was that Africa
would provide the bodies on the ground
the soldiers and the big powers would
provide the logistics and the funding
the US government pledged to give fifty
million dollars but did not give a cent
not one cent
the Canadians pledged to provide
helicopters and pilots but they rented
civilian helicopters from Eastern Europe
and hired civilian pilots from Eastern
Europe civilian pilots have the right to
refuse to go into a battle zone the
European Union promised to pay the
salaries of the African Union soldiers
when I was in Darfur in 2007 they had
not been paid their salary for eight
months because the European Union said
they were not sure that the money was
going to Darfur they thought there was
corruption in Addis Ababa I have never
heard a war where because the
bureaucrats are corrupt the soldiers are
not paid well if you're not paid for
eight months in a strange country how do
you live all kinds of corruption
proliferated and all of this was
reported in the press the point was to
discredit the African Union soldiers and
to replace them with a UN Command the
point was not to replace the soldiers
the soldiers remained on the ground the
point was to shift the command from
Africa to New York this has been a
systematic attempt a systematic attempt
to discredit both any kind of political
solution any kind of African solution to
an African problem and instead there has
been a call for external intervention
and military intervention starting with
a no-fly zone which I will come to my
notion of what is a better solution
later thank you thank you
I've been being happily rendered
entirely irrelevant I don't even have
any time to keep John we're going into
what are we doing we're in 15 minutes of
the way forward now no no the rebuttal
isn't supposed to start until the next
steps out it's the way forward you could
hijack the thing if you wanted but we'll
respect that process way forward yes boy
there's a lot I want to respond to but
we shall wait for later extreme
discipline the way forward I want to
talk about the major diplomatic
opportunity that exists in in Darfur
today with all of the contentions and
differences in the international system
where the United States the backdrop of
Iraq and all that that spawn in terms of
divisions and Lebanon and and even
Afghanistan going forward remarkably
despite all that we just heard and
despite all of the the divisive 'no
Security Council the United Nations has
experienced on Darfur remarkably there
does exist a fairly substantial
consensus for peace in Darfur globally
China Arab League African Union European
Union United States most Sudan's
population
everyone wants peace but we're not
working together for it multilaterally
internationally this is where I think
the greatest opportunity exists for the
new administration in Washington and the
new president and his new envoy Scott
Gration a deal for Darfur a peace deal
for Darfur is available to be brokered
and the need for international
cooperation to implement the north-south
peace
Steele has never been more urgent I had
the opportunity to meet with President
Obama a week and a half ago about Sudan
in the West Wing
to talk about the way forward and his
special envoy was about to go out on his
first trip and I found refreshing after
quite a number of years of obfuscation
and divided efforts during the previous
administration efforts that were deeply
undermined by our counterterrorism
relationship with the Sudanese
government deeply undermined by our fear
of upsetting China with respect to many
of our other equities in the bilateral
relationship with that country and our
diversion the diversion of our energy
assets and resources and attention to
Iraq it was refreshing to see the
president stride into the room and say
very very clearly and confidently it's
better than any Sudan expert in the
United States government could have
possibly stated that there will be many
challenges there will be everyday a
firehose of emergencies that come out of
the spout that is Sudan but we will
focus our attention and maintain our
attention on the strategic prize which
is peace in the country and that means
supporting peace in Darfur and
implementing peace in between the north
and the south and insuring against
conflict in the east and the far north
where rumblings are always heard I spent
this morning along those same lines with
the president Sarkozy chief advisor on
Africa and he had nearly the identical
view that we need now is the moment to
work for peace in Darfur I've spent time
in here in this town with the Chinese
ambassador to the United Nations
recently same thing
meant a number of Arab League
representatives same thing we have an
opportunity here folks to to move the
ball forward even with all of the
divisions and all the debates on Sudan
and all the issues that have marked a
very divisive last few years on Darfur
we can I think resolve help to bring a
resolution to the crisis there to that
end I think the president of our country
here in the United States needs to put a
put the resources to bring the resources
to bear for that we I had the
opportunity to spend a great deal of
time between 2000 while I was still
working for the last the previous
President Clinton and then in helping
some of the the emissaries the diplomats
in in the peace process that followed
the end of the Clinton administration
that followed for the north-south peace
deal and that carefully constructed
process which had been years in the
making which had the leadership of a
Africa a Kenyan General Lazarus and a
whoa backed very closely by the United
States Britain Norway in a number of
other countries from the region in
African and the surrounding and across
the Red Sea
brought what most people at the time
thought and at the time it was the
deadliest war in the world two million
people estimates I'm sure professor mom
Donny would probably have a dispute with
that number but those those were the
highest mortality figures after Congo of
anywhere in the world since the
Holocaust and most people thought yeah
there's no way you're gonna get these
guys to agree you anything and a very
concerted diplomatic effort led by the
African mediator but closely supported
by the United States and a number of
other countries around the world brought
pressure to bear on the parties the
rebels in the South the government in
khartoum
brought and offered incentives as well
to a peaceful resolution and they
managed to come up with a very
complicated but a very successful peace
deal the same can be done now for Darfur
it is it is there to be picked it is
ripe as professor zartmann would say for
you Seba fans of that kind of ideology
we need I think to present the Sudanese
government with a door one and a door
two and do the same with the rebels
very simply door one if the government
restores aid access allows for
assistance to to flow to the people who
are in so desperately in need of that
assistance and address the leadership
crisis and work for peace then there
should be a clear path to normalization
with the United States and other
countries that have had significant and
serious bilateral problems with the
Sudanese regime given all of the human
rights abuses has been accused of door
to on the other hand if they continue to
use starvation and thirst and disease as
weapons of war
if Bashir remains defiant if there's no
progress towards peace in Darfur and if
there's an upsetting of the applecart in
the peace process and the implementation
of the seat of the north-south peace
deal then we need to prepare for
diplomatic economic and as a last resort
let me be very very clear about this and
hopefully we'll have time to debate and
discuss what we mean when we talk about
the possible use of military force and
for what purposes a very very last
resort then there ought to be planning
at least just as there ought to have
been planning in 1993 in early 1994 in
preparation for what ended up happening
in Rwanda which we were totally
unprepared for and uninterested in after
our Blackhawks were shot down in Somalia
so it'd be criminally irresponsible for
us not to prepare for scenarios in which
thousands and thousands of people starve
if assistance is cut off for extended
periods of time which I do not think
the Sudanese government will do however
you plan for those eventualities
remember the policy status quo in Sudan
has led to what I believe to be and that
is certainly a word I don't think it I
believe it to be and what's very
different concept to an accorded to two
and a half million lives lost during
this twenty to twenty five year period
of warfare in southern Sudan and in
Darfur those are the all the mortality
estimates thrown together and maybe it's
stupid frankly to talk about the numbers
of people dying because we don't really
know having spent most of my adult life
working in war zones in Africa I can
tell you most of these figures are wild
estimates I mean they're they're simply
crazily wild estimates occasionally you
get credible mortality data but it's
usually very localized so people then
extrapolate beyond that local area then
they multiply by this area and then they
figure out well this area had this level
of death crude death immortelle
mortality rates six months ago so let's
add that together and at the end of the
day it's not really credible we don't
know if it's one hundred and fifty two
hundred fifty four hundred thousand five
hundred thousand people who have died in
Darfur and frankly it's not something
that we're ever going to know the
evidence of all these crimes will have
been washed away in the sands of the
Sahara long after we can begin the
picking apart of all of the questions
about estimates but I do know that the
number of debt dead and the number of
disease and number of people who will
suffer enormous Lee will increase
exponentially if we do not act boldly
diplomatically to try to help bring
peace into Darfur how much done
five minutes okay so I give you in five
minutes
what I think are five windows of
opportunity why it is this moment that
peace is possible in Sudan amidst all of
the dreariness of all the negativity all
the pessimism about the direction that
country is going here's why I think with
real concerted diplomatic work the
United States and other countries that
care working with Sudanese can bring
about the change first window is
something we haven't talked much about
yet but will I'm sure at some point the
war crimes indictment of the
International Criminal Court this has
been highly destabilizing internally to
the ruling party in the National
Congress party inside Khartoum and it
provides a tremendous new source of
influence for the international
community to leverage peace in Sudan in
exchange for the elusive article 16 the
ability to suspend these cases defer
these cases in the interest of
international peace which is part and
parcel of the International Criminal
Court's mandate and charter second
window of opportunity I think concerns
China China as many of you know is
invested
we estimate eight and a half billion
dollars in the oil sector in Sudan now I
just my last two visits to Southern
Sudan not Darfur but southern Sudan and
I've spent a lot of time with the former
rebels there who lived trying to become
the government there in southern today
and every one of them said if we go back
to war and the if is a big one the
possibilities are very very high at this
point if we go back to war if the
referendum does not occur our first
target is going to be the Chinese oil
installations so I came back to the New
York came back here and talked to the
Chinese ambassador was a horrified
because their interlocutor is only the
ruling party in Khartoum who will never
tell them that their assets are at risk
because of instability so they have a
vested interest in
instability why is the United States not
working hand-in-hand closely with China
for very different reasons to bring
about the same objective that we would
like to see happen in Sudan which is
peace the third window of opportunity is
the election that's going to occur at
the beginning of 2010
now with elections of course this isn't
going to be a free and fair election no
one's gonna put this one up in the
poster of love of successful African
elections during the last decade but all
kinds of political alliances are
possible and the incumbent president by
the way is going to be as he runs if he
runs if he lasts that long and indicted
war criminal and that will have
consequences that are very very
unpredictable it's a major opportunity
if we play if we undertake a creative
diplomacy working with some of the
regional actors who are fed up with best
year for many reasons not only how he
treats his own population but his
support for Hamas and other kinds of
things that have an impact in the Arab
League the fourth window of opportunity
is the new president in Washington this
is one that I think rebounds in a lot of
places around the world and it's a
complete unknown and it may not last
very long but because he's new because
of who he is because of the interest
that he has demonstrated on these issues
because he's traveled there because he
said
khartoum embassy person said he may
actually travel to sudan later this year
for all these reasons obama becomes a
wild card in all of this if he engages
in his administration engages quite
substantially just like bush was the
wild card in southern sudan because of
the critic conservative christian
lobbies that generated and fueled his
interest in enthusiasm and trying to do
something positive in southern sudan
similarly you have a president now who
is willing to engage in his and and
wants to help bring about a solution
that's quite a substantial opportunity
window of opportunity fifth and final
window is a strange one it's you frankly
you know for the first time since the
word genocide was invented after the
world war ii we are seeing the formation
of a mass movement of people all across
the united states to help stop these
atrocities now of course I will not
quibble with president with Professor
mom Donny it is a different situation
than it was at the outset of the Darfur
war in 2003-2004 when there was active
village burnings and the
counterinsurgency was was the deadliest
in in the world but having people and
that's why I started my whole
interventions this evening with a
description of what life is like for
somebody in the in a camp and that
person most of those people that ended
up in those camps were driven out of
their homes out of their villages by
that counterinsurgency campaign in the
government city and so we can cripple a
quibble all day of whether it's better
or worse or how many people died or how
many people haven't died but it is
unacceptable people have to live like
this and now to have the aid tap turned
off as a systematic way of punishing
collectively people who have the gall to
rebel because of historic
marginalization so I think very very
much that the fifth and final window of
opportunity are people like yourselves
are willing to show up who willing to
care
who actually most of you I imagine are
probably motivated in some way shape or
form by a desire to see the suffering of
these people and one way or another
however it happens and I think that that
sentiment has translated I can tell you
it's translated directly to President
Obama busy told me he said one of the
main reasons why his administration is
going to be able to act with all of the
other things that are going on in the
world because there is this Lobby there
is this constituency people care about
what is happening that is significant
and that is a huge window of opportunity
Thank You professor mom'd on the way
forward
I come from Uganda and I was amongst
those expelled in 72 by DME because I
come from ancestrally from India I went
back in 79 Muslim when I mean was
expelled and I used to hear figures of
how many died in Uganda under the Amin
regime 1 million dead I went around to
around the country I was there from 79
to 1996 long period and I concluded that
these figures couldn't be believed there
are 4 confirmed my suspicions when I
listened to John talked about with total
confidence 2 million died
in South Sudan two and a half million in
South Sudan and Darfur and then almost
in a Cavalier way we will never know
which figures are true they may be true
they may not be true the only
explanation I have is the following the
estimates of the dead are usually done
by agencies whose funding depends on how
many have died
or are about to die or are at risk when
they are inflating the numbers of the
Dead or those at risk they are writing a
funding application we should take it as
such the US government has not spoken
with one voice actually there's been a
division between Congress and the State
Department Colin Powell was in Darfur he
was on his way out
at her home Airport he was interviewed
by the media there's an NPR report I
quote it in my book Paul was asked time
and again is there a genocide in Darfur
and Powell said every time no my lawyers
have told me no there is no genocide in
Darfur on his way Powell found out
otherwise from his boss in his career as
Secretary of State Powell
two times bent to the pressure of the
force brought on him but not the force
of the evidence before him
Bush's special envoy to Darfur Andrew
not CIO's read his testimony before the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee a
couple of years ago and he is adamant
he's adamant he's questioned about the
rape and he says that rape takes place
wherever
the young men confront unarmed women
whether it's in the rebel camps whether
it's in government control camps in
Darfur whether it's in Sierra Leone
whether it's in Congo whether it's in
Iraq whether it's in Afghanistan or
whether it's in the United States it's a
larger problem and it needs to be
addressed as such
I'll come to the question of military
forces the last resort I'm shocked to
hear that if they don't do what we ask
them to do then military force right
that's what we're being told ok so let's
take thee there are two alternatives
before us on what to do one alternative
is summed up in the the ICC case the
International Criminal Court now a
couple of things about the ICC the
prosecute that genocide was unfolding so
that's not at issue but the Court did
upheld uphold its claim that a crime
against humanity had taken place in
Darfur it is that if the facts as stated
in the application of the prosecutor are
true if the facts are true then there is
a case to answer so on that basis the
court issued the summons the facts are
not yet on trial this was a pre-trial
hearing if there is a trial the facts
will be on trial what I have said in my
previous nobody knows Holmes further
says two hundred thousand died from
combined causes doesn't tell us what the
combined causes are but presumably
drought in desertification is one of
them and then one says that if the rate
of death remained the same then three
hundred thousand must have died but it
didn't remain the same in fact declined
dramatically so that's the first thing
that any trial would have to question
second thing the child would have to
question did the causes of death
seventy-nine to 1996 long period and I
concluded that these figures we believed
that that force must be a last last
resort
thus my alarm at adhering all the talk
about continuing genocide because all
this talk feeds into the rhetoric of
those who look for a military solution
more troops no-fly zone
and and and those who seem to have no
interest whatsoever when the chips are
down in a political solution now I
recognize that John spent a good bit of
time talking about the possibility of a
political solution and I think that that
is an admirable adjustment to the new
situation today it is clear that in the
period after the international NGOs were
kicked out of Sudan INGOs small number
of NGOs were kicked out of Sudan it is
clear that the initial demand from the
Save Darfur movement etc was for a heavy
direct response but it's clear that the
US administration has been backtracking
and this is I think unnecessary and an
admirable adjustment to an understanding
of realities on the ground as I said
before there has been a difference
between the State Department and
Congress Congress has been driven by the
Save Darfur activists themselves the
State Department has been a little more
realistic about this and one can only
hope that there'll be two changes one
that the presidency will not respond to
the bellicose nature of the movement
organized around Save Darfur and true
one can hope that the movement organized
around Darfur will become more informed
less bellicose and more political in its
aspirations thank you
thank you very much okay so now for for
each of our speakers there'll be an
opportunity to to rebut and to state
some conclusions and then we'll go to
questions
so John thanks Peter first of a note
about the objectives of the if we can
just I know you're short-handed when you
say Save Darfur is it sort of a the the
mishmash of activists all over the
country with pressing fees for quite
some time now the activists have been
focused very very exclusively on what
I've been trying to articulate which is
a much more effective political response
from the previous administration and now
the new one piece is the objective of
the peace agreement in Darfur and an
implementation of this comprehensive
peace agreement in the north-south deal
is the objective of the Save Darfur
coalition and a number of the other
organizations that are associated with
it or work in tandem with it that's what
they do that's what they're for and any
other frankly and let me tell you this
very very clearly any other
representation of their position or our
position is a distortion of that
position secondly the mortality figures
let's see where we agree we agree the
figures have declined the the level of
mortality has declined since the height
as we said of 2003 and for the
preponderance of the those that have
perished have died as as in any war in
conflict related causes disease
malnutrition and and thirst in the
Sahara not by gun shot or machete or
helicopter gunship so you know I don't
know where the dispute is frankly and
then thirdly what why I say we don't
know and why I would then say this next
sentence would be it's vastly under
counted is because there are huge swaths
of territory just as in southern Sudan
and why the death count was so high in
the South there are huge swathes of
territory during the last six years that
been rendered inaccessible to aid
agencies either because the government
of Sudan has made them no-go areas or
because of insecurity so we simply have
no idea what is going on with respect to
mortality in some of these areas that
are inaccessible now these are displaced
people as well these are people who have
had their way of life and way of living
disrupted massively over the last few
years the economy of Darfur frankly has
never talked about but is in a
depression because the the
interrelationship the inter-communal
kinship relationships that had been
established over generations have been
destroyed by this divided and destroyed
policy of the government so most people
are in dire straits and so when you have
months and sometimes years of
inaccessibility to aid to assistance we
can only guess and I can't do better
than that frankly and I'm trying to be
honest with you I think the numbers that
are thrown around are just estimates
they are not even estimates
third point I would like to make in
responses is this point about rape I
couldn't let that go I mean rape is a
tool of war in Darfur and you have to
spend time there to understand how
intrinsic it is to the effort by the
government of Sudan to destroy these
communities you have to sit and talk to
women all day long who tell you and then
show you the marks as they've been
branded I mean this isn't fabrication
this is not New York City there are
sexual violence everywhere in some way
shape or form yes but this is a
systematic approach as a method and tool
of conflict a method tool of submission
and subjugation hugely important issue
for the people of Darfur maybe not so
convenient here fourth let's clarify the
use of military force I can tell you
that no credible person in the activist
community that anyone takes seriously
has called for military occupation of
Darfur no one has talked about that
there are two positions that have been
credibly put forward and this is where
we are anything else is a distortion so
I'll tell you what they are now
first and foremost rooted in
international law the United Nations
Security Council is three times censored
the government of Sudan for using
offensive military flights against
civilian targets China and Russia voted
for these resolutions so was in a US
Western plot this was what the world
believes is happening in Darfur and
three times the United Nations Security
Council not the Save Darfur movement
said they put forward resolutions that
banned offensive military flights by the
government of Sudan now we all know that
most cases the United Nations Security
Council is a feckless institution
operationally but they put forth their
best effort at saying what the world
thinks and they tried to condemn this
use this tool of terrorism against
civilian population which is aerial
bombardment a critical by the way
advantage that the government of Sudan
has over the rebels in Darfur it is the
reason why they've won they've been
winning the war it's because of air
superiority unchallenged air superiority
so when we talk about use of force first
and foremost it is an enforcement of the
band that the United Nations Security
Council has already voted three times so
understand that okay and then secondly
what has been talked about more recently
as a last resort
please follow it is if there is a
sustained and systematic obstruction of
humanitarian assistance I said if in
Darfur and if the mortality rates
skyrocket if we start to see the kind of
images we've seen in so many African
Wars where people are systematically
denied assistance on the basis of either
political or affiliation or their
identity and if we are unprepared to do
anything about that I should find that
rather negligible so I negligence so I
would hope that
would be undertaking scenario planning
to see what possibilities exist for the
deployment of sufficient assets to
deliver humanitarian assistance should
we come to that point those are the two
I think approaches that activists have
put forward as possible uses of military
force there is no other next point is
this question of genocide in the ICC
which was also distorted that the judges
did not throw out this prosecutors
charge of genocide that he tried to have
brought to the case there are three
judges that consider the evidence that
the prosecutor brings one judge said I
agree it's genocide there's enough
evidence I vote for it did you know that
two the other two judges said wait a
minute
there isn't enough evidence on the on
the issue of intent this is the
interesting thing about the definition
of genocide the perpetrator if it's to
be considered genocide and international
law and it's a very very disputed issue
as we've seen tonight and everyone in
this room knows for genocide to occur
the perpetrator has to intend to destroy
it can't just be a byproduct of one's
counterinsurgency operation so two of
them of the three one said yes it's
genocide two of them said we don't have
enough evidence of intent we're going to
keep the case open keep providing us
evidence and we will rule on this later
they didn't throw it out fifth is the
issue of justice now I think
conscientious people can disagree about
this question and I think we can put
forward a number of different cases all
over the cotton round the world where at
times transitional justice at times that
Truth and Reconciliation commissions and
those kinds of things are the best way
forward and at other times the justice
in the courtroom is required and I think
at this juncture to end this cycle of
impunity that is fueled and driven
conflict destructive conflict in
Soudan since the independence of that
country I think it requires some measure
of accountability in a court and I think
that Basheer's case is more akin to
Milosevic and Charles Taylor than it is
to de Klerk from South Africa and that
was where I would come down but I do
respect very very fully that and I think
was quite brilliant on the part of the
architects of the International Criminal
Court as they put for it put together
the the the charter of that institution
which allows for the deferral of a case
on the basis or in the interests of
international peace so if indeed there
was peace in Darfur if this president in
cart Khartoum signed a peace deal with
Darfur and implemented a peace deal and
the South I would be the first person in
line to be arguing for an article 16
deferral because that's what the Charter
of the International Criminal Court
intended Thanks well
the fact is the judges of the ICC's
throughout the charge of genocide two to
one that's the truth in conflicts there
are deaths directly from the conflict
and there are conflict related deaths
and usually conflict related deaths are
more so how do you tell which of the
deaths from other causes are or are not
conflict related it's very difficult
except in this case the death from
drought and desertification begins
before the conflict because the conflict
begins 87 89 then it stops and the
conflict we're talking about the phase
of the conflict is 2003 2004 the drought
and desertification and the deaths from
it are already intense by the mid 80s
when you think about the international
NGOs keep one thing in mind the
international NGOs are no longer your
humble community-level
effort the largest of the international
NGO has an annual budget of over two
billion dollars billion not million it's
larger than the annual budget of most
African countries so these are powerful
organizations the conflict between
international NGOs and the African
governments has been over who is
sovereign the international NGOs demand
that African governments do not monitor
them do not supervise them let them do
anything they want to do why because
they claim to be doing it in the
interest of victims African governments
governments in general claimed to be
speaking not for victims but for
citizens and I will develop this
question of the difference between
citizen and victim in a minute but first
with the Save Darfur movement Save
Darfur began as a an alliance of
religious movements if you enter the
rally the first big rally in New York
City they passed out faith packets at
the rally Christian faith packets Jewish
faith packets Muslim faith packets the
Christian faith packet told you that the
Lord had empowered Christians to lead
humanity the Jewish faith packet told
its reader that the Lord had made Jews
particularly sensitive to sensing
genocide when it occurs and the Muslim
faith packet said that Muslims were
particularly well-placed to identify
perpetrators of genocide
so you can already tell right at the
beginning the point of view of this body
which came together now there wasn't a
single point of view there were multiple
points of views there was and I say this
in my book there were some of those who
had historically been linked to the
movement to solidarity with the rebel
movement in South Sudan and who assumed
that Darfur was just another version of
South Sudan but Darfur wasn't the South
Sudan insurgency began from the very
outset as an insurgency against the
government in Darfur the conflict began
as a civil war in South Sudan the
government tried to turn it into a civil
war there was a big difference
that is why in Darfur you don't have one
movement you don't have a John Garang
but you have incredibly fractionalized
movements the international NGOs in
Darfur have assumed that to be an Arab
in Darfur is to be a perpetrator I last
week I was speaking in Tufts at Tufts
University at an institute where whose
researchers work in northern Darfur and
I asked them can you figure out why they
decided to dismiss these to throw out
these international NGOs and not others
they said yes because these are the ones
who never employ and out of Darfur these
are the ones who will not let an Arab
Darfur into their camp these are the
ones who see their camps as basically
camps for victims who they see is non
Arab only from the point of view of the
government they have exacerbated the
conflict rather than solved it now I
want to say something about Save Darfur
movement itself I said it was remarkably
successful and it was patterned
initially after the peace movement of
the 1960's except that Save Darfur is
not a peace movement Save Darfur is a
war mobilization listen to the slogans
boots on the ground out of Iraq into
Darfur those are not slogans of a peace
movement
I went when I went to Darfur 2008 I said
to the UN humanitarian officer rights it
saved our food gathered 50 15 million
dollars from contributions last year how
much did it send to Darfur he said
nothing I said nothing I came back here
I asked to Save Darfur person that I was
told you sent nothing he said yes we are
not an agency we are an advocacy group
Save Darfur employs an advertising
agency 24 hours a day seven days a week
it is a lavish advertisement putting out
the figures that you read none of which
are credible it has a contempt for facts
which parallels those who are so
intoxicated with power in the words of
Senator Fulbright at the time of the
Vietnam War it is symptomatic of the
arrogance of power the facts that this
movement gives out are completely
decontextualize go to a Save Darfur site
website what you will find on this
website is a documentation of atrocities
no history no politics nothing tells you
why there is violence all you see is
evidence of killing raping ethnic
cleansing I call it a pornography of
violence a form of voyeurism it is meant
for the good of the one who views it not
for the good of the one who is being
viewed the focus is on naming and
shaming on punishment on criminal
justice the demand is not reformed the
demand is punishment as if they are
lusting for blood it is I believe
seamlessly a part of the war on terror
because the underlying assumption is if
the problem is violence the solution is
more violence and yet the amazing thing
is that the Save Darfur mobilisation
precisely when its propaganda was come
more and more divorced from the facts on
the ground its mobilization was more and
more successful and I want to say this
to you and to others who have seen this
urbanization because there is reason for
concern there is a big contrast between
the priest movement of the 60s and the
Save Darfur movement today the police
movement of the 60s turned the world
into a classroom its signature activity
was the teach in Save Darfur has turned
the world into an advertising medium it
relates to its constituency not as an
educator but as an advertiser it is not
created or even tried to create an
informed movement but a feel-good
constituency its focus you can see is
increasingly shifting from college
students to high school kids
these are saved our fourth version of
child soldiers it's its leaders that's
two minutes left its leaders are less
educators there are more celebrities
from high-profile activities showbiz and
sports they openly disdained education
and debate the court the CNN effect my
puzzle was when I was trying to study
this movement in 2006-2007 and I knew
there were American soldiers in Iraq and
I knew the atrocities in Iraq were much
worse my puzzle was why for my students
and my son's classmates why would they
be mobilized around Darfur and not
around Iraq and I realized that Iraq
calls on Americans to respond as
citizens a student who thinks of Iraq
realizes either he feels or she feels
guilty or he or she feels impotent that
there are limits to American power when
it comes to Darfur these same students
do not relate to Darfur as citizens they
relate to Darfur as humans and they do
not relate to Darfur easy citizens but
as victims when I first came to the US
which was as a student in 1963 I
remember being so surprised to being in
a because I was in a place where people
were so generous they gave
so freely to charities and yet these
same people were so stingy when it came
to paying tax I realized that the very
people who were paying millions to
charities would spend millions to hire
lawyers so they didn't have to pay more
tax I realized that Darfur is a charity
Iraq is a tax in Darfur these same
students can feel what they know they
are not in Iraq powerful saviors in
their food the assumption is as
throughout the world witness John's
words that if they don't make it right
we must go and make it right the
assumption is that the problem is
internal the solution is external the US
has to learn to live in the world not to
occupy it thank you so we'll be moving
on to questions and I have as people
would like to line up to give questions
why don't you get ready I'm gonna ask if
I'm gonna take the moderators
prerogative and pose my own to start but
I would ask when you give when you ask
your question
identify yourself make the questions
short and I'd like to ask the audience
not to applaud either during the
questions either from the to the
questioner or to the respondent but my
own questions John first and then to
Mahmood mobilization is a scary thing
and always leads to excess whenever any
movement is taken on an issue that I
know well it scares the daylights out of
me and and in listening to you carefully
I actually think you're scared and I
wonder if you might comment because I I
hear in what you're saying that you have
a big concern that we're not talking
about which is the end of the
comprehensive peace accord and Sudan and
the the possibility of the North and
South going back to war and however we
quibble about those numbers the one
thing we do know is a lot more people
died in the conflict with southern Sudan
and the horror that we might be facing
if we see that war start up again will
dwarf anything perhaps that we've seen
in Darfur and I actually hear that you
sort of inserted that in a very quiet
sort of
getting way almost in your comments and
and if I were you I would be scared
because the mobilized community around
Darfur actually doesn't know the first
thing about the comprehensive peace
agreement you've said that you're that
the the the advocacy position is peace
in Sudan but but that's not what the
people know I don't think I mean tell me
if I'm wrong but I really don't think so
I think actually you and I are pretty
old and that the stories of southern
Sudan have been largely forgotten in a
very strange way and that something
horrible is out there and and that's the
big story and the Save Darfur
mobilization may not be what's going to
get us there and neither the indictment
and I and I was intrigued by and pleased
to hear your discussion of the
possibility of a compromise or of a
Security Council intervention in Sudan
on the on the on the indictment it'd be
interesting to know what conditions you
think are necessary for that to happen
mom would my question to you I I've
asked this I suppose in different ways
as a practitioner in human rights the
one thing that I know are that there are
unexpected consequences all over the
place and and on every major position
I've taken on international justice I've
been wrong the Pinochet indictment
caused me the heebie jeebies it was
tariffs they're really upsetting to see
Spain a country that had never faced its
past indict the leader of a country
Chile a former leader in Chile under
circumstances that seemed to be divorced
from the reality in Chile and yet the
effect has been amazingly positive and
and for reasons entirely beyond our
anticipation that the arrests in London
helped us set back in motion the the the
the the legal process in Chile in a way
that made people able to get beyond
Pinochet in ways that was completely
unpredictable the arrest of Charles
Taylor the indictment of Charles Taylor
from a legal point of view absurd it
wasn't within the mandate there was no
right for a for this mixed tribunal to
indict Charles Taylor it was an insult
to Ghana the context in which it took
place and yet it worked that's almost
the only thing I can say at the end of
the day is that it worked now we know
that the circumstances are very
different
but but what would make you step back
and say gosh I couldn't have imagined it
but it worked it set something in motion
what would that look like
I think you know a 2003 to 2004
no one knew what a dark bore was and
there was a concerted effort by people
all over this country who did know to
teach others and there was this
wonderful new development call you know
that allowed for mobilization virally
which you know 10 15 years ago with
peace movements or these kinds of things
we wouldn't have been able to get to
remotely the number of people that have
learned about Darfur through
internet-based social marketing based
sources so I think that that means that
the problem that you're outlining that
people don't know about Southern Sudan
is a is not as formidable as it would
have been 10 or 15 years ago because
part of what we've tried to do over the
last year as we've tried to assert a
little more put a little more adult
supervision into this into this into
this movement is in addition to pressing
for a clear objective of peace in Sudan
as the fundamental objective not the
other things you're hearing secondly
that there is a important the importance
the overriding importance of an all
Sudan solution that indeed North far
north is vulnerable to an potential
conflict the East has seen conflict and
will see it again if their issues are
unaddressed on the borders of Eritrea
Ethiopia the South sadly will rise again
if we do not see the implementation
fully of this north-south deal and and
Darfur so I think there is there is a
great deal of education going on now
more of an all Sudan solution I do want
to say one thing and you can flash me
the the the minute card as soon as you
want about this question of saved off
well I don't work for the Save Darfur
coalition but I do want to say that it
is it is an advocacy group it doesn't
pretend to be a humanitarian group and
then collect money and then only do
advocacy advocacy Washington DC New York
City full of groups that are advocacy
groups that's what they do they're
trying to change United States
government or UN policy it's what their
objective is its primary focus and I
need to reiterate this over and over
again please get on the website as
Professor mom Donny has challenged you
to do you will find in fact that the
objective of the organization is indeed
piece for Sudan
it also lobbies for humanitarian
assistance so taking that little
piddling amounts of few million dollars
that it can raise and hopefully
translating that into tens of millions
and hundreds of millions sadly which are
necessary to keep people alive in the
current construct in Darfur their budget
is not remotely close to fifteen million
dollars now you can look it up and I'm
sure if you google the phalanx of actors
just googled George Clooney and his army
of high school soldiers you'll find that
pretty consistently the message is in
favor and in support of us engagement
for peace in Sudan that is what the
Darfur movement is about not military
occupation of Sudan well I am glad you
recognized the necessity for adult
supervision of the child soldiers of
this movement
well a to the chairs question look hey I
don't deny at all that the Pinochet
Fujimori Charles Taylor is a bit more
complicated these cases were salutary
but my suggestion would be to recognize
that there's a difference between
criminal justice in cases where the
conflict has ended and prioritizing
criminal justice in ongoing conflicts
that is the first big difference between
Darfur and and in the Chile or Peru or
any of these cases in fact if we look at
other cases in Latin America wherever
the military handed over power in most
cases where the military handed over
power to civilian governments part of
the deal was that the military will not
be put on trial you will not be put on
trial and over power even if you look at
the de Soviet ization experience in
Eastern Europe look at his Germany East
Germany where the new government
publicly pledged that it will make
public the names of informers in Stasi
and it opened the books and started
making these names public and then
realized the names were so many that if
they made them all public it risked
starting a civil war and it stopped the
exercise think of Spain after the Civil
War decades of amnesia it's debatable
and it is debated but what I'm saying is
what I mean is that this is nothing new
this is nothing new when a conflict is
ongoing and you're faced with the
challenge of how do you stop it and how
do you make the peace durable what kind
of political reform is necessary then
you prioritize political reform over
criminal justice you prioritize the
welfare of living individuals over
punishing in the living groups over
punishing individual perpetrators
let me just say one last thing which is
look the safe that for example shows
Save Darfur movement had a salutary
effect at the beginning it did publicize
this violence but having done it it
simply went on its own merry course
uninterested in what was happening in
Darfur completely uninterested
uninterested in the opportunities of
peace simply wanting to build a movement
in the United States the ICC case itself
also as a threat can have a salutary
effect in terms of promoting reform but
if the threat threat is delivered the
unintended consequences will be terrible
including the the agreement in the South
coming unhinged thank you Thanks so no
applause during the questions excellent
good start let's start with the
questions here identify yourself and and
ask your question I'll really project
now you have to stand in front of it if
it still doesn't
oh yeah I'll just hold it it seemed to
some extent in the rebuttals that you
were responding to each other
substantively but not really
conceptually and it seemed like it felt
at least for me like watching a debate
between block or you know Madison and
Foucault where on the one hand you're
concentrating on individual saw net
debate and professor McDaniel you're
focusing on institutions of violence and
history and so I guess I I wanted to ask
each of you a question to try to maybe
you know really work out the
difficulties of consolidating these
positions and professor Mamdani I guess
my question to you is what do we do
about the people in the camps and and
for you mr. prenderghast
how do you reinterpret your confidence
in international law the UN and Western
interventions in light of Professor Mom
Danny's critiques
great question um let's begin with the
recognition that in every case that I
know over the last few decades in Africa
we're either as a result of famine or
war you had a huge number of IDPs
in camps in every one of these cases
there was a confrontation between the
international NGOs and the government of
the day in Ethiopia in Rwanda when it
came to the IDPs in eastern Congo and
now in Darfur and the question was about
who is sovereign well the international
NGOs operate under government monitoring
under the monitoring of the sovereign or
will they not operate under this
monitoring the challenge for the
governing power is of course in on
enormous you know when I was in in in
Darfur in these meetings and I remember
in the meeting with the IDPs I was so
shocked that they totally believed the
the Save Darfur messages that they
completely believed that their salvation
lay in UN soldiers rather than African
Union soldiers when we told them that
when the UN comes in the soldiers will
still be African only the command will
be in New York City they couldn't
believe it they kept them saying no we
want white soldiers we want white
soldiers we want white soldiers the
problem is that the IDPs
have gradually made have been made into
what they were said to be at the
beginning which is victims which is
wards which is objects of charity how do
you what kind of transition is necessary
to move
from that to citizenship and that
transition is more than simply providing
for the food that they need or the
medicine that they need that I think
will be the easier part of the
transition but the crucial question is
and I am NOT going to lay out a
blueprint here I can't lay out a
blueprint the crucial question is if
citizenship is to be part of that
transition it has to be an internal
process now one final thing if if an
external intervention let's imagine a
situation where the external
intervention is absolutely necessary
where should it come from my view is
that in such a case the external
intervention has to be original
it cannot be by the big powers the
intervention must be by those who are
your peers who can imagine themselves in
your shoes and it must be by those who
are your neighbors who will have to face
the consequences of the intervention not
by distant big powers who have the
luxury to leave as they have from
Afghanistan time and again and to let us
suffer the consequences
the saved our foot notion and the
international NGO notion is simply one
in a line of recipes we have received
since independence starting with
structural adjustment program you come
you give a blueprint
whatever the consequence is you don't
have to face them they have to be faced
by the people on the ground
I am NOT talking of an intervention by
individual countries like Uganda and
Rwanda and Congo or if your Pia in
Somalia or become proxies of some big
power I am talking of an intervention
through a regional mechanism with some
possibility of accountability thank you
so I think the best-case scenario over
over the next decade would be we start
to see some of the those that have been
indicted by the International Criminal
Court from the Congo for example the
warlords from natori I began to be
convicted for recruiting child soldiers
and some of the other war crimes that
they have been charged with in the ICC
that Joseph Kony and the other leaders
of the Lord's Resistance Army would be
captured and apprehended and brought to
justice in the hague for the crimes that
they've committed throughout the last 20
years Africa's longest war that Bashir
ends up being convicted for war crimes
and crimes against humanity including in
the words of the of the court the same
judges who throughout throughout
genocide two to one extermination and
rape that he faced justice in that way
and then we have against the backdrop
those cases against the backdrop of
their National Criminal Tribunal for you
Slavia an International Criminal
Tribunal for Rwanda and the special
court for Sierra Leone and the new
Courtenay Cambodia and slowly and the
Pinochet case and others and slowly but
surely there begins to develop best case
scenario a deterrent to war crimes and
crimes against humanity over the coming
decade and that governments and rebel
groups have to think twice John let me
just interrupt because I think I've I'm
worried that you're maybe to just push
you a little bit in the wolfram my so
that my elegant students question gets
answered if you takes if I if I take
seriously some of the things that Mahmud
is saying I fear the opposite in each of
the cases that you've just mentioned I
fear that the ICC is becoming
discredited and so its legitimacy will
never build because and I would and I
would go further and I would say because
actually they're in trouble in the Congo
because they're in trouble in Uganda and
now in the way they've moved in
to Sudan they're in trouble further and
even if you believe what you believe
even if even if you believe that the
views of professor Mamdani are are
ill-founded can you consider the
possibility that actually the courts
legitimacy itself in Africa is now being
undermined and it's being viewed as an
imperial entity and that that's going to
undermine the possibilities of the
courts of two to seven things don't pile
on first there is a similar pattern that
one has to definitely acknowledge that
in the case for example of Charles
Taylor when the special court for Sierra
Leone issued its indictment for him and
he laughed as Bashir is laughing now and
people said my god doesn't this diminish
the credibility of this little court
here as it tries to figure out what it's
gonna do in 18 months later he's in the
dock and The Hague let's see okay and
when Milosevic was and you just a person
whose grace these halls here talked to
Richard Holbrooke about Milosevic his
first reactions to his to his indictment
by the International Criminal Tribunal
for you to Slavia very similar to and
it's dismissal to to Bashir and we have
the same you know very difficult startup
periods for the International Criminal
Tribunal for Rwanda which was I just
remember years of corruption and
overspending and all kinds of things
that just made you just demoralized the
the proponents of justice and sadly this
is when you create international and
multilateral institutions they tend to
work fairly badly early on and and
hopefully with good leadership can the
ship can be righted and we can see some
successes and I think it's going to be
uneven I don't think it's gonna be a
slam I don't think it's going to be
complete success or complete failure I
think we're gonna stumble along for a
while in the
the universal gray area where some of
the cases in Congo for example finally
come to court this this fall and we
start to see some convictions and maybe
Kony gets apprehended or maybe he
doesn't maybe one of the Sudanese gets
caught maybe he doesn't we'll see more
people convicted in Rwanda we'll see
more will see some start up in Cambodia
and this will stumble along and my hope
is and I'm really trying to answer the
question my hope is that that over time
that over time when with a with a
backdrop of more success stories rather
than those early moments where it looks
pretty bleak as it has for the first
five years of the ICC which does not
have a conviction yet that five years
from now when there are and ten years
from now when it's a more credible
institution we will hope then it might
be a different story we might be having
a different conversation
that's my hope it's not my belief that's
my hope and I think most of us activists
are sustained by hope more than anything
else in our careers all right well we
have a lot of people have been patiently
waiting so let's let's hear and just
introduce yourself quickly and good
evening my name is Dana Niaga I'm from
Southern Sudan I live here in New York
and if I may may take a minute because I
think they're certain erroneous
statements made by mum Danny that need
to be clarified
unfortunately Save Darfur representative
was not here I had hoped that they'll be
here but I'd like to tell the organizers
of such meetings in the future if you
organizing anything about Sudan and
Darfur in particular please don't have
three white men sitting there talking
about you know our issues please
audience don't because we are here and
some of us have been involved in moving
the issue around therefore since they
started well let's try not to be too
mean in our ad hominem comments but let
me just ask you this can you be pointed
and say the things you think were false
and just indirect those to him so that
he can respond so for his assumptions I
said dr. foo coalition is all by white
people and Jewish people in particular
is false
men over sudanese both from the south
and from Darfur I mean from Darfur have
been working and actually before the
Darfur coalition became Darfur collision
men of us were working and we've been
there in the middle of it and now
actually through self dead refer
coalition you have there are four
leadership network in the Diaspora but
of course Mamdani will not tell you that
and he talks about international NGOs
and young millions of dollars and yet he
is at the bastion of intellectual
superiority a white institution here in
Colombia and yet he is against anyone
trying to help people in the refugees
and secondly look at how he talks about
displaced people in the refugees they
don't know anything they believed that
white people were coming to save them as
if we as black people and I use these
words very carefully we are like make
the distinction we don't know we can
never speak for ourselves and I say
Colombia's next to here how many of you
here in this room go to Harlem right
across from you how many you know so
let's really put fuck's secondly what is
so important about the numbers would one
person who got killed make it any less a
problem would it
why are we so stuck on the numbers you
know so my question to him is in a
country as divided as Sudan in a country
that has since pre independence been in
conflict with yourself where certain
segments of his people have consistently
been denied what Mamdani called
citizenship what does he suggest these
people should do and what does he
suggest the international community
should do because we are part of the
international community so thank you
very much and I appreciate your no
please I think we really if we can't
start be of applause will won't be here
forever but I think it's very important
to have people I mean I need to have you
here and just to say as well that every
conversation can't include all
subjects and all participants but I
think directing the questions to
Professor mandanas is fair and I'm sure
it'll be happy to respond thank you let
me just say I never said that Save
Darfur is an organization of white and
Jewish people
I said saved our food began as an
organization of religious groups and
then it expanded and it was I said
spectacularly successful and it spanned
into all kinds of groups mmm so that
just just to be clear about that but let
me come to your question in a country as
divided as Sudan what should we do when
certain segments have been denied
citizenship yeah we're talking of Darfur
okay and I'll confine myself to Darfur
as I pointed out the conflict in Darfur
began as a civil war not as an
insurgency against the central
government it began as a civil war
between two groups the starting point
was actually 1981 when a Darfur governor
was appointed because at that point
there developed a schism between
peasants and nomads and that schism also
became one at its heart between Arab and
non-arab groups Arab nomads and non Arab
peasants if you go to Darfur the poorest
of the poor in Darfur are the Arab
tribes of Darfur no matter what
indicator you take whether it is income
whether it is employment whether it is
numbers in schools whether it is number
of professionals the most wretched group
are the Arab tribes of Darfur even if
you take the peace negotiations the
groups that have been left out of the
peace negotiations from Abuja onwards
have been the Arab tribes of Darfur the
negotiations are between rebels level
movements and the government and the
Arab tribes have been demonized as
Janjaweed so if we're talking of
citizenship we're talking of citizenship
not simply for one group in Darfur
talking of citizenship across the board
the answer to that cannot come from the
international community I will ask you
to remember only one thing the League of
Nations promised in after the first
world war that it would establish a
trusteeship in different colonies so
that the populations of these colonies
could be moved to self-government one of
the colonies where they established
trusteeship through Belgium was Rwanda
and the changes they brought in Rwanda
were the backdrop to the genocide in
Rwanda I asked you not to listen to the
promises but to study a little bit of
history I understand the pain that you
feel I have absolutely no no no no
critique no problem but I simply advise
caution thank you so let's take a few
questions if it's possible why don't we
take a couple and come back to it my
name is Mohammad Ali I'm from Sudan from
Darfur region my question to my Dean he
said the civil wars is start before 2003
that's not correct my my father and my
brother they kill in 2003 by John DeWitt
and Sue Ann Gavin so and my wife swept
front of me by the genuine I waiting for
ICC a way to Verizon see how he says
ICC's disaster is not disaster I'm
waiting for ICC so the war is start in
2003 one the government and joined elite
they wanna kill us
that's this genocide my abilities my
towel is destroyed by a by aircraft
that's your aircrafts that come from
Middle East it's not come from appliques
not come from United States it's come
from the
government is it destroyed my town they
killed my father they kill my big
brother and they read my file my wife
run off me you say before the war is
that the civil war they're in there for
you that's not true
I'm from Darfur I'm from Sudan I'm Sarah
I know was born exactly in Darfur so if
you were or whatever you have with the
government if you want to talk to that
for you have to be honest you miss out
thank you good evening my name is Elena
tansy and I'm a SEPA second year setting
security policy I'm in mom Donnie's
class and also the TA for the genocide
prevention class so so you live in
eternal conflict and as a result I have
two questions at first I was nervous
about approaching professor mom Donnie
and since I had to see him on Monday we
won't tell him about this question all
right so my question for professor mom
Donnie is in the beginning you made the
comparison between Rwanda and the kind
of black hole of information and
international media and the surprise and
reaction to conflicts that are not
really that surprising or that knew how
much international attention and what
kind of international attention do you
really feel is helpful or how do you
think that would help because that's
always a question of international will
and that kind of intervention question
for mr. Prendergast is how would you
incorporate regional organizations and
Africans institutions this solution
thank you thank you my name is Sir my
name is Hamza brahim I'm from Darfur I'm
a victim of that government but from
professor and then he's talking about
history he's not gonna live with the
reality this year students he should
tell them what next step they can do
what you're talking about history about
ro and ice that's long time ago but
that's you gonna tell these people and
confusing us anyone over that I'm a
victim of this government and another
thing
see all the story he told about this
audience it is not it's not time these
people they come over there they said
that the world in doctor
yes Civil War that's not true we know
that his troops done these people they
know how to meet this army student they
are adult so you can come sit down here
find out this people are you telling
that he didn't kill the people give our
peoples and he's going to be accountable
for but you should I'm not insulting you
I respect you that you see you said over
here is not honest as is not true I
don't know when you go to Darfur you see
them he comes everybody sees those
people in refugee comes humble that he
stopped I have the palms and say and you
keep saying the citizen they can pay
with those African countries yes the
African countries they can't do what
they wanna do but that mean you consider
that there is no international community
to do anything but America can't kill
anybody
nobody anything African government can
take the people's nobody can come over
there and tell them that mean you Allah
kill their institutions of business that
what you say everybody and I'm a victim
not gonna let my place is not gonna away
from justice in ICC so thank you thank
you hi I'm Diane Bennett and I have two
hats one I work for Bill easterly at NYU
professor easterly and I run the
Development Research Institute there
where we are working to help understand
how do we help the poor people in this
world to create solutions effectively
the other is that I've worked in Sudan
for the last ten years in South Sudan up
against the Ethiopian border near malik
al which has been a flashpoint a number
of times the last few years and where i
would predict that when and if war comes
back that's definitely going to be play
a major part i would really love to see
peace in Sudan that is what I have
worked on on the ground for the
ten years I'd like to hear both of you
talk about what do you think is the road
briefly to that and how do we get there
and I believe in a free and open
election I know the census is being
taken right now in both the north and
the south and there's word on the ground
that is being sabotaged by the
government of Sudan that northerners are
being moved into the Nuba Mountains so
they can artificially count numbers and
so on I wonder what your understanding
is of the situation and whether there's
credence to the census so why don't we
take some responses from the feminists
so first just a general reaction to some
of what we've just heard it's a really
different conversation frankly when you
go to Darfur or when you go to southern
Sudan and as I've been doing for the
last 25 years and talk to the million
and of course you can't have that but
representative selections of millions of
people who have been displaced such a
euphemism by the cycles of conflict and
the government of Sudan's policies of
its approach to counterinsurgency I
think you've heard a slice of the
emotion in the reaction tonight from the
southern Sudanese woman at the beginning
and then two of the Darfurians who
demand justice frankly and that I think
their voices should be factored into our
assessment all of us each individually
as we try to understand what is the way
forward
in incidence why goes frequently because
I think you have to ground test your own
ideas and thoughts about how things
ought to be at to go forward otherwise
it's all very theoretical and academic
to answer professor mom student on how
to involve regional organizations I
think that the there are clear rules for
for the for the Africa in African Union
is partnering with
the United Nations both to sponsor the
special envoy who will eventually lead
the peace process in in Darfur and they
are of course the main participant and
contributors is Professor mark to the
United Nations African Union but there
is no peace yet to keep so they end up
button down in there with both
government and rebel representatives in
Darfur as well as with civil society
groups you get very rapidly a sense that
there are only a few issues and those
issues there is increasing consonants
around those issues therefore back to
point a we've got to have a structure in
place a process in place that can get a
deal on the table and then the leverage
applied and the pressures and incentives
applied to make sure that the parties
agree and then implement I think it's
all within the realm of the possible the
very near-term possible and I am very
very hopeful that that the new
administration here in Washington will
be a central catalyst for getting this
moving forward as fast as possible to
help bring about an end to the suffering
of the people of Sudan that's prime time
thank you
in my very first 15 minutes on the
podium I said that if you remove all the
exaggerations one claim stance one fact
remains which is that in 2003 2004 the
government of Sudan carried out its own
war on terror there were anything like
roughly 50,000 people who died of direct
violence this is mass slaughter right it
is true should we be less worried since
the number is not 400,000 I wasn't
saying that I was simply saying what is
the politics of those who think that the
higher the numbers the better is there
case
I was asking us to just be mindful of
that so the real question is not simply
the history of it we try to understand
the history to answer the question what
next what should we be doing and to the
student of Foucault and you Mike who is
looking for a conceptual distinction let
me say this a the real difference
between the two positions being put
forth here is on the question of how to
move forward they saved our full
position or the position of that section
of the human rights movement which is
inside Save Darfur is basically that you
must focus on the atrocities and hold
accountable the perpetrators of those
atrocities my position is different I
think that that's not and cannot be the
priority it cannot be the priority
because violence is always driven by
issues the idea that violence is its own
explanation
that the violent are simply violent and
the only way to do it violence is to do
away with those who have been violent I
think is a mistaken proposition if we
accept that violence is driven by issues
and that if you do not deal with those
issues the cycle of violence will go on
no matter how many criminal trials in
half then the first priority has to be
to address the issues even if it means
not having criminal trials that's the
position I've put forth which is why I
have argued that Darfur cannot just
stand in for South Sudan which cannot
just stand in for Rwanda we have to
understand the violence contextually
because if we don't understand it
contextually and historically we will
not put our finger on the issues third
question the situation in the lady from
the easterly research unit the situation
is we move to the referendum what are
the big questions and what's the way to
peace you know about six months ago I
think it was I had a meeting with the
SPLA ministers in the Sudan government
about four of them and in this meeting
it became clear to me that one of the
biggest issue dividing the government of
Sudan the Islamist component of it
and their partners in the government the
SPLA was the question of who should have
the right to vote in the referendum on
the South more specifically should South
Sudanese living outside South Sudan have
right or not and in particular the South
Sudanese who are in Khartoum who number
in the millions IDPs in the millions
should they have the right to vote in
the referendum one side said no and that
was the SPLA side which said that we
believed that their vote will be
manipulated by the government in the
north and the northern side said no
because if these people don't vote we'll
be left with that problem at the end of
it if you decide to secede we will be
left with the problem of the IDPs in the
North now of course the government has
done its own share to influence the IDPs
in the north which is it has given them
land it has given them titles over land
so that they have a stake in staying in
the north but you can expect these
manoeuvres on on on on both sides how do
you get peace I believe that the process
that led to the agreement in South Sudan
is is the best guide that's the kind of
agreement not exactly that agreement but
that's the kind of agreement that we
could do within Darfur
keeping in mind that be since Darfur is
both an insurgency counterinsurgency and
the civil war that preceded it this
issues that led to the civil war will
not be solved by a South Sudan type of
agreement because the issue that led to
the civil war was the land question it
will have to be addressed difficult as
it is it will have to be addressed
final question grew under well you know
I'm afraid the safe careful movement has
drawn simply the wrong lessons from
Rwanda the lesson they have drawn from
Rwanda is that if only they had been a
us-led military intervention in Rwanda
well there would have been no genocide I
disagree completely my own sense is that
the genocide unfolded because the
political settlement arrived that in
Arusha did not hold it did not hold for
two reasons
because the right-wing the Hutu
extremist group was not given
representation in Arusha and had no
stake in the settlement that came out of
Arusha and secondly because the RPF was
not interested in sharing power the RPF
wanted the whole cake in nothing but the
cake and the US government intervened in
rwanda indirectly by supporting the RPF
by giving a nod to the Ugandan troops
which were part of the RPF and basically
believed that an RPF victory was
necessary the French government I will
not go on and on also intervened through
a palacio to causes the lesson of Rwanda
I believe has to be different the other
I think a regrettable conclusion that
Save Darfur has taken out of Rwanda is
that sometimes situations are so urgent
that you must not analyze them you must
simply act it has split knowing from
acting that knowing is a luxury in an
emergency yeah I find it completely
absurd if somebody is critically ill and
and and you say there is no time for
diagnosis just prescribe and then you
turn around and say who will prescribe
only those most outraged and most
concerned should prescribe it's absurd
you would never accept that in a
situation where you will face the
consequences of such an intervention but
that is what we are being told by those
who lead the child soldiers of Save
Darfur
we have time for another round of
questions ten more minutes okay let's
have a few more questions let me just
say that the voices of the victims and
including the pain is something that
belongs here I agree but I think we
should consider sort of excluding words
like wire and accusations of insincerity
and demonizing from
comments thank you my name is Mohammad
Avila and I'm from Darfur and I just
come from that for two months ago and
it's clear that two panelists they've
been in Darfur but both of them from
different ways maybe been Durga's been
in Darfur from chat site and professor
Mandana from the Sudan government side
and he just saw the prepare it IDP comes
round al-fashir town which are prepared
we call them five stars
IDP camps and he don't know how the
others living really I lost from my
entire family 47 people all of them
direct killing by air bomb I mean
probably bender has been in my village
called MOSFET in north north part of
Darfur
this is first where the drought start we
start from that point because I am
living very close to the border of Libya
and not none of them killed by the
drought you mentioned so that's not true
and also you give wrong name for the
conflict which is a civil war no there
is yes I agree there is a small
confluence between among the tribes in
there for 4 years ago but that not civil
war because that limited conflicts and
people able to contend at that limits by
tribal leaders so you given wrong when I
am walking to this debate I'm hoping
panelist giving the correct information
to this intellectuals so they can help
us to get out from where dilemma we are
in but unfortunately I really am was
disappointed when professor mentioned
the history of the conflicts and given
wrong name and given these intellectuals
around informations thank you for know I
didn't come to my question yet oh you
know what there's no longer any time I'm
afraid
I'm serious we have to we have ten
minutes for everybody else to be able to
present their questions what you have
can get it out 1/2 a second that's fine
ok how many people must be killed so we
got to name it genocide first way thank
second one
no thank you yes hi my name is Rhonda
Chafee I am a student in Columbia
College and I have two questions very
brief questions regarding the
globalization of the Darfur issue my
first question is that it was reported
two months ago that a scoop of Somali
pirates seized a Ukrainian ship carrying
3.2 million dollars worth of arms for
southern Sudan and my question is that
can we draw any conclusions or can
anything be said about the globalization
of not only the southern Sudanese
question but also the Darfur issue based
on this recent development and then my
second question is somewhat related
recently there's been a lot of
discussion surrounding the increased
possibility of a southern to southern
secession in Sudan and my question is is
there anything at stake what is that
stake
if southern student is to secede in the
near future thank you thank you my name
is Ed abuse if I'm working for an
organization called Sudan social
development organization pseudo that is
one of the organizations were closed
down by Sudanese government being
working in their food and hearing
professor Muhammad an is speaking I
think he's defending this the next
government modern Sudanese government
himself and another question for John
Prendergast I hear you speaking about
the way forward I also hear that this
peace process that carried out by the
American and supposed to take place in
Nairobi Kenya it is the same way that
you are talking about of this the peace
process well whether he's the one that's
plan for Nairobi meetings in Nairobi
yeah is it the same things that you are
talking about this is different a
different thing
thank you I'm Sharon Beth long and I'm
with the New York City Coalition for
Darfur part of the Save Darfur movement
actually I want to thank dr. Madani
for his
nuanced analysis of the movement it gave
me some pause and some things to think
about my question is does dr. Madani
think that the ICC indictment might lead
to more revenge against civilians or
have a backlash against civilians second
what does what does both dr. Madani and
dr. Prendergast think of the divestment
movement especially directed at China
and third doctor Prendergast mentioned
areas of consensus
what should the Save Darfur movement and
international governments want to see in
a peace agreement what would cause what
type of agreement would cause both sides
to put down their arms so let's hear
though from the last people are standing
and then we may not get to all of the
answers but let's with those just the
ones we're still standing so first of
all process em I'm done I agree with the
analogy that gay 35 men but I also think
that there are instances when when a
person situation is very critical
doctors try to send it to the person or
do something in order to keep the person
stabilized before they finally put the
knife on the person to a print and I
think that is basically what everyone is
asking for that instead of waiting and
you know arguing about and Corizon
why don't we try to figure out how the
black poor can be halted momentum and
what people try to agree the other thing
that I also just want to ask is
basically I understand that the US
intervention I mean everyone looks upon
US intervention with so much suspicion
however if you want to look at what
happened recently in Zimbabwe where
Mugabe basically has been allowed to
take the helm of affairs
you can we all realize that
some ways somehow Mugabi because of the
you know because he's then come and
already had so much power he is
basically monopolizing the transference
of power we also understand that based
on the history of colonialism and the
business relations between a lot of
international communities and African
countries somewhere somehow there is
always going to be a foreign country
that is influenced in whoever the local
government is so Mugabe for instance is
receiving arms from China and we cannot
say that you know another foreign
country shouldn't intervene so that
there is a balance of power so I just
want to know how you analyze the
international levels of analysis
involved and I guess the last no no
that's it thank you very much so very
quickly good I see that I'm actually
trying the patience of the panelists
along with liberal studies human rights
program OVR columbia i my question is
specifically for you differentiate it
between the direct killings that are
taking place on the ground that are
taking place due to other external
factors like i'll start over you
differentiate differentiate it between
the direct killings that are taking
place on the ground and other causes
such as the desert vacation of the
sahara desert and then just keeping in
mind that the crime of genocide is does
not just encompass direct deaths it
actually also encompasses the critical
element of creating conditions are
calculated to bring about the
destruction of life and noting that
currently eight groups have been
expelled and so many people in these
refugee camps to depend on them for
their further for their livelihoods to
stay alive is this not furthering the
genocide that's my question for you
thank you hi my name is Dina Guster and
I attended the college the journalism
school in the School of International
and public affairs and when I first
arrived at Columbia six years ago I
became immediately involved in the
anti-war coalition and the reason why I
bring up this point is because I do
think it's incredibly fascinating how
this movement around Darfur has evolved
and this quest
for mr. prenderghast and I have no doubt
that you share my concern for suffering
people as I believe most people in this
auditorium to do but I am curious why
you think that this cause in particular
especially how it's been framed in very
stark terms about an oppressor and an
oppressed about people who can
externally be redeemed by Western
intervention has taken such a toll on
the public imagination and galvanized so
many people for right or wrong reasons
compared to the Iraq war where our very
direct tax dollars are paying for
cluster munitions white phosphorus and
according to the New England Journal of
Medicine have killed a million people
thank you as I said we may not get to
all the answers but it looks like some
people are sitting tight and waiting so
yeah so that's interesting go back to we
have a bunch of things here Columbia's
college student about the Pirates in it
and the ship that was captured that the
tanks in it for the SPLA Dustin for the
SPLA everyone knows I think that the
government they actually the ruling
party the National Congress party and
the SPLM are both importing weapons in
advance of what they both believe may be
a return to war Biff the referendum
doesn't occur there's a
an oil fuel arms race that is continuing
i only thing that we learned from that
incident is the SPO lays purchases maybe
not so smart because buying those kinds
of tanks and that terrain is not going
to be doing so that's all I get out of
that what is at stake for the referendum
much more important question is that the
every southerner every southern Sudanese
is holding their breath for this
referendum it's it's referendum or war
for most southerners they will go back
to war they will do so regretfully but
they will go if this referendum doesn't
occur the stakes are breathtaking the
high and that's why just as and back to
your question earlier Peter and just as
much as we have to work assiduously
globally for a peace in Darfur we
similarly have to work equally for the
implementation of that peace deal
between the north and the south and
getting that referendum up and held
otherwise there will be a war much
bigger than that that exists in Darfur
today that resumes in the south I don't
know about those Nairobi talks but if
you want to come up afterwards we can
try to figure out what you meant by that
I just don't know what they are the
third question that I see is this
question about the divestment and China
and I think it's an important tool
because what divestment has done over
the last few years it has vested local
communities around the United States
whether they're universities or local or
municipalities or states where local
activists can try to make a difference
right there in their own backyard with
respect to the the investment decisions
that either their state their city or
their educational institution makes with
Russo they can encourage that the the
investments are not going to support in
any way shape or form the government of
Sudan and the
and the violence that it has been
culpable in perpetrating in Sudan in
Darfur so I think those that have been
very very well it's been a very
important part of the movement structure
substance of a peace deal in Darfur I
think the as I said there the the issues
are clarifying dismantling of the
paramilitary infrastructures otherwise
known as Janjaweed dealing with some of
the essential power and wealth sharing
elements of a deal for the Darfurians
some regional additional regional
autonomy and then what may be the most
important issue for every and any
Darfurian that you speak to is some
measure of individual compensation for
the losses this is a core demand of
every Darfurian I've ever spoken to in
Darfur and in the refugee camps and it
is a symbolic as well as real in the
sense that having lost everything as a
result of the government's
counterinsurgency strategy they want and
it's not they don't want a World Bank
trust fund or something like that to pay
to do development projects they want the
government of Sudan as the as a
principle perpetrator of the violence in
Darfur that drove people into the camps
for the first two or three years of this
conflict to pay individual compensation
to people who are aggrieved and the
government has already accepted this in
principle it's been a question simply of
a negotiating numbers is it 30 million
three hundred million what and that is
going to be the essence of then of the
of the peace process
thank you well I guess let me repeat
that eh I didn't go to Darfur with the
government of Sudan I went with the
African Union I didn't say that the
conflict in Darfur is a civil war I said
it began as a civil war okay
it is both an insurgency and a
counterinsurgency and it was a civil war
which has now fuelled the insurgency and
the counterinsurgency but let me make a
more substantive point him the role of
victims in a solution in a conflict I
think this question and the answer to
this question has to do with our
understanding of the role of history in
the relationship between history and the
future now I have been both surprised
and reassured by victim voices here who
have said let's forget history let's
just talk about the future itself the
reason I've been reassured is because
usually victims don't want to forget
history if you remember South Africa and
remember the Steve Biko trial and the
Steve Biko trial the murderers of Steve
Biko well-known the Supreme Court the
court threw it out basically because it
would have undermined the political
settlement in South Africa the Magnus
Malan trial Magnus Milan's role in
counterinsurgency and everything was
well known but it was thrown out again
because of presumably larger interests
and because history must be subordinated
to the future if we are to have a future
otherwise we will have endless cycles of
revenge how many people must be killed
before we call this a genocide the
interesting thing is that genocide is
not about the numbers killed read the
report of the UN Commission Commission
on Darfur and compare it with the ICC
prosecutors report the disagreement is
not about numbers the disagreement is
about what to call it think about think
about violence in contemporary conflicts
I asked you to consider a couple of
facts one that modern wars and modern
conflicts have become total wars
they are no longer Wars just between
armies and two sides there are wars
where armies attack not only the
opposing army but the entire economic
infrastructure and civilian
infrastructure now we have a language
where we have different words for some
killings we call them genocide some mass
killings and different words for other
mass killings which we call war or
counterinsurgency I think we are in
danger of distinguishing normal violence
from bad violence and we are in danger
of accepting certain kinds of violence
as normal as maybe even good violence
because they are the antidote to bad
violence I just ask you to think about
this more next question direct killings
and other causes all I'm saying is that
there have been multiple causes let's
just recognize that right it's not
simply spillover effect of the violence
because the drought and desertification
preceded the violence and will continue
after the violence is stopped right and
the deaths from it will continue after
the violence is stopped
just as the causes of the Civil War
continue even when the counterinsurgency
and the insurgency have stopped and do
we want to wait until the facts remind
us of the case or do we want to
recognize that these are no matter how
entangle they are they are analytically
separate issues which need to be
separately considered China and well you
know look I don't know why people are so
hyped up about China I mean why look
there's a resource conflict the u.s. is
neck deep in Chad American oil companies
are neck deep in Chad and chaplain and
and and China is neck deep in Sudan
they're both having access to oil in
these two neighboring countries if you
want to talk of provision of military
hardware everybody knows that half the
money spent in this world of military
equipment is spent by the US Army the
rest of the world put together
barely equals US military expenditure so
if you want to do away with war and
violence start at home was this China
but complete diversion total diversion
total lack of understanding of what the
global situation is but pointing to a
real possible danger in the real
possible danger is that we are in a
transitional situation with a declining
power and a rising power and we need all
the sanity we can possess to not beef up
things and not hype up things and and I
I hope I hope we can muster that sanity
final Zimbabwe in Kenya look Mugabe okay
Mugabe Zimbabwe hey look here there were
elections in both these places Zimbabwe
in Kenya there were charges of rigging
the charge of rigging in Kenya was
greater than in Zimbabwe there was
violence that followed the election the
numbers of people killed in Kenya were
much more than in Zimbabwe and yet the
US government the British government
everybody put together prevailed on the
different parties in Kenya to come
together in a coalition government but
they did their utmost to prevent the
adversaries in Zimbabwe from coming
together in a coalition government the
only reason there's been a coalition in
Zimbabwe is because the region southern
Africa in particular stood against
Western pressure I believe that a
coalition government in a divided
country because no matter whose figures
you take the figures were roughly 50%
give or take a few percent on one side
50% on the other side this is a divided
country you have to have shared power
you can't have winner-take-all that is a
recipe for restarting the civil war same
problem in any other continuing conflict
like therefore thank you let me thank
the participants the the panelists and
thank you to the audience this was
really a pleasure
thank you thank you guys sorry about
that
any questions
you